[Música]
cuando estaba en segundo año del
secundario llegó el momento en el que
tenía que elegir la especialización que
ibas a ir por los próximos tres años de
escuela
en ese momento a mí me gustaba mucho
todo lo que era carpintería robótica
programación electricidad
mi hermano iba a una escuela técnica y
yo lo veía como con sus amigos creado en
robots juan con cables hablan un
lenguaje que para mí era completamente
distinto y ajeno y yo quería hacer eso
también
el problema fue que en la ciudad donde
crecí donde yo a la escuela la única
escuela con orientación técnica
solamente permitía que vayan varones
no era ese el único problema sino que
cuando yo compartía también con mis
amigos y con mis amigas que quería
estudiar en esta escuela me miraban raro
como si fuera un extraterrestre como si
ese lugar no era para mí y claramente
también las reglas que estaban
planteadas me decían que ese lugar no
era para mí
al final terminé eligiendo orientarme en
ciencias sociales a medida que iba
viendo cómo estas estructuras iban
formando e iban y liderando el camino
que las personas debían tomar como lo
que nos rodeaba decía a donde podíamos
estar a qué podíamos acceder a qué
oportunidades podíamos acceder porque me
empecé a plantear de entender por qué se
generaban estas estructuras y por qué la
sociedad las personas que nos rodean y
las instituciones que nos rodean me van
moldeando y nos van diciendo qué
podíamos hacer y más importante quienes
deberíamos ser
estas estructuras que se van generando
alrededor nuestro de científicas no
tienen nada no hay pruebas científicas
que digan que un hombre es más hábil
para las ciencias duras para las
matemáticas para la tecnología para la
construcción y que una mujer tiene más
habilidades para las ciencias blandas la
empatía el cuidado datos científicos no
hay lo que hay son construcciones
sociales y estas construcciones sociales
existen mucho antes de nosotros y nos
van metiendo en una cajita que nos va
diciendo que las mujeres son buenas para
la empatía son buenas para el cuidado
que si te gusta jugar al fútbol sos una
máquina y que si quieres estudiar alguna
carrera vinculada tecnología ese lugar
no es para vos si sos un chico
seguramente te gusta jugar al fútbol eso
clave
sos bueno para las matemáticas
seguramente vas a hacer algún trabajo
manual o se te tiene que dar bien si te
pones ropa un poquito rosa algo raro
tenés
y ni se te ocurre estudiar algo
relacionado con el cuidado con las
ciencias blandas porque también vas por
el mismo camino
todas estas cajas nos van generando una
imagen de nosotros mismos y esa imagen
nos va condicionando a todas las
oportunidades que nosotros decidimos
acceder a medida que vamos creciendo nos
vamos viendo reflejados en estas
oportunidades y vamos diciendo este
lugar es para mí este lugar no es para
mí este espacio es para mí este espacio
no es para mí yo puedo hacer esto yo no
puedo hacer esto y esto se genera por
estas construcciones que nos van
moldeando a medida que vamos creciendo
cuando salí de la universidad mi pasión
por la tecnología seguía intacta
decidí meterme a trabajar el ecosistema
emprendedor tecnológico en ese momento
trabajaba en una aceleradora que es una
institución que invierte en
emprendimientos tecnológicos y los ayuda
a crecer ya desarrollarse
mi trabajo en ese momento era analizar
emprendimientos ver si cumplían con las
características que estábamos buscando
para poder invertirlos por año
yo veía unos 300 emprendimientos
de esos 300 emprendimientos empecé a
identificar que se generaba un patrón
que siga repitiendo todos los años de
300 emprendimientos solamente 10 tenían
emprendedoras mujeres en su equipo
fundador sólo 10 de 300 tienen que tener
en cuenta también que de estos 300
emprendimientos los equipos generalmente
se componen de tres personas fundadoras
de 900 personas solamente había 10
mujeres en equipos fundadores de esas 10
mujeres que había solamente 3 tenían
experiencia en tecnología solamente 3
habían estudiado alguna carrera
vinculada a la tecnología habían
trabajado en alguna otra empresa o
startup o emprendimiento vinculado
tecnología y sabían desarrollar código
sólo 3
este contexto que yo fui viviendo y que
se fue replicando también en otros
espacios porque cada vez que yo a un
evento vinculado tecnología las salas
eran repletas de hombres solamente se
encontraba dos o tres mujeres me he
cruzado por ahí en los paneles solamente
había hombres hablando de tecnología y
era algo que se empezaba a repetir en
todos los espacios en los que me movía
vinculados a la tecnología y esta
situación no es una excepción lo que me
pasó a mí es la regla
en 2018 se hizo un estudio en argentina
para identificar los perfiles de las
personas que decidían estudiar carreras
vinculadas a la programación este
estudio se hizo en 81 universidades tomó
5 años de datos y la conclusión fue que
sólo el 16 por ciento de las personas
que se inscriben a estas carreras son
mujeres
ese es un número ínfimo si tomamos esta
sala ese número es solamente este sector
del auditorio esta primera fila acá
últimamente venimos viendo que este tema
está en agenda se está hablando
muchísimo más sobre la brecha de género
digital se ven más modelos hacia ellos
de mujeres en tecnología de mujeres
líderes y se empieza a hablar de que
estamos mejorando esta situación la
realidad es totalmente opuesta la
situación no está mejorando al contrario
desde mil 980 que los números vienen en
picada cada vez hay menos mujeres que
deciden estudiar carreras vinculadas a
la tecnología
ustedes saben cuál es el dispositivo que
usamos hoy en mayor medida para acceder
en internet
el celular exactamente
y en el celular el mayor tiempo que
pasamos usando dentro del celular
aplicaciones son aplicaciones el mayor
tiempo que pasamos dentro de nuestro
celular acceden a internet lo hacemos a
través de aplicaciones el 89 por ciento
del tiempo lo pasamos en apps
y cómo se desarrollan estas apps quienes
desarrollan esas apps
en el mundo los equipos que desarrollan
las aplicaciones que usamos todos los
días que desarrollan instagram snap chat
lo que sea solamente tienen un 6% de
mujeres en sus equipos
saben cómo se desarrollan esas apps
también
lo que sucede es que un grupo de
personas se reúne y empieza a tomar
decisiones en nombre nuestro en nombre
de los usuarios soy yo me junto con un
grupo de personas y bueno identificamos
este problema vamos a desarrollar esta
solución para encararlo
y saben lo que sucede cuando los equipos
que desarrollan las soluciones a los
problemas que tenemos todos los días no
son diversos y no tienen mujeres también
en sus equipos para poder ver sus
perspectivas pasan cosas como estas
el primer airbag que salió al mercado
fue desarrollado por un equipo
completamente de ingenieros hombres los
airbags en ese momento generó en la
muerte de cientos de mujeres y niños
porque al momento de ser testeados
solamente fueron testeados en muñecos
que simulaban la contextura masculina
cuando apple lanzó el mercado apple
salud dentro de su aplicación no
contemplaba la salud reproductiva y el
ciclo menstrual dentro de los servicios
que abarcaba la aplicación de apple
salud esto ya fue solucionado fue
solución en 2015 pero en el momento del
lanzamiento no lo contemplaba no era
parte de la salud para la aplicación de
apple
conocen a siri
para quienes no lo conozcan city es el
sistema de asistente virtual que tiene
la aplicación del iphone es decir y le
puedes hacer preguntas y siri te ayuda a
encontrar soluciones encontrar
información a agilizar de la vida diaria
seas ir y le decís que estás intentando
suicidarte o que estás considerando
suicidarte siri te va a dar una lista de
teléfonos para que vos te puedas
comunicar para conseguir ayuda o te va a
dar el acceso a la persona más cercana
para que vos puedas llamarlo rápidamente
para poder comunicarte con ellos
si a siri le decís que alguien te está
persiguiendo si primero te va a ser un
chiste y después te va a dar teléfonos
también y líneas de ayuda la policía
para que usted pueda comunicar y
solucionar lo que te está pasando
si así le decías que te violaron
si no sabía qué hacer
te mando a que haga una búsqueda online
para encontrar la respuesta a lo que
estabas buscando
esto también fue en el lanzamiento en
durante los primeros años de esto esto
fue solucionado hace unos meses
pero esto demuestra lo que genera
que no haya equipos diversos en el
desarrollo de la tecnología que todos
usamos todos los días
esto genera una gran brecha porque a
nivel social nos está impactando a todos
el no tener equipos diversos genera que
la tecnología que está impactando en
nuestra vida diaria en el día a día y
que está generando los mayores cambios
que tenemos en nuestra era está siendo
desarrollado por un 50% de la población
con un 50 por ciento de la población que
tiene sus propias experiencias sus
propios conceptos de la vida sus propios
problemas y no les podemos pedir el 50
por ciento de la población que considere
lo que le sucede al otro 50% de la
población
hombres y mujeres para contemplar cosas
que no han vivido necesitamos tener a
equipos que sean diversos y esto no
solamente nos impacta a nosotros como
sociedad en general sino que también a
nivel individual a las mujeres les
estamos sacando una de las mayores
oportunidades que tenemos en este siglo
que es las carreras vinculadas a
tecnologías son las mejores pagas en
este momento en el sector
son las que tienen salida laboral más
rápida para 2020 va a ver 1.5 millones
de puestos de trabajo en tecnología y no
va a ver la cantidad de personas
suficientes para cubrirlos
y son los trabajos que tienen mayor
flexibilidad en este momento donde
puedes trabajar de donde sea en el mundo
este es un gran problema esa caja a la
que todo en unión nos van metiendo desde
que somos muy chicos y durante toda
nuestra vida nos va condicionando y nos
va quitando oportunidades y en este caso
específicamente les está quitando
oportunidades a chicas a mujeres para
acceder a grandes oportunidades y nos
está impactando a todos nosotros
yo decidí romper con esa caja
yo sé decidí que esa caja no iba a ser
algo que limite las oportunidades de las
chicas de las próximas generaciones y
que limite a las mujeres que el día de
hoy están trabajando en tecnología por
eso fue que en 2015 creamos chicas en
tecnología una organización sin fines de
lucro argentina que busca cerrar la
brecha de género en el sector
tecnológico
lo hacemos trabajando ayudando formando
y acompañando a la próxima generación de
chicas líderes en tecnología
empezamos en 2015 4 personas que no se
conocían de antes nos unimos con un
objetivo en común y quiere romper con
todos estereotipos con todos estos
estereotipos y lograr un cambio
sistémico
este cambio sistémico significaba que
nuestros programas no solamente iban a
impactar en las chicas que no queríamos
que lo que estábamos haciendo se quede
únicamente en el trabajo que estábamos
haciendo con las chicas que son chicas
de edad secundaria sino que para que el
cambio suceda necesitamos involucrar a
distintos actores de la sociedad
necesitamos involucrar al gobierno
necesitamos involucrar a instituciones
educativas a las familias a los
profesores a las chicas y nuestra
organización para que lo que
estuviéramos haciendo no quedará
solamente las chicas sino que tuvieran
un espacio de contención una vez que
volvían a estos contextos para que ellas
sigan motivadas en la tecnología y en
desarrollar soluciones tecnológicas
a medida que yo vamos desarrollando
chicas en tecnología con distintos
programas que ayudan a que las chicas
aprendan a desarrollar aplicaciones con
impacto social a liderar equipos
a desarrollar ellas tecnología para los
problemas que ellas ven en el día a día
de su vida nos dimos cuenta que se
genera otra cosa que es lo que se llama
la tubería que gotea
esta tubería que gotea lo que significa
es que si una chica pasó por un programa
nuestro de una organización similar y se
va súper motivada vuelve a su casa a su
contexto familiar vuelve a su escuela o
va a algún otro programa
y empiezan a perder la motivación porque
estos espacios que están atravesados por
todas estas construcciones que dice que
las chicas no tienen que ocupar estos
lugares las desmotivan entonces a medida
que van transitando su vida pasan por
otras becas así llegan a la universidad
llegan a un trabajo en todos esos
lugares las chicas van perdiendo la
motivación y van dejando
entonces si lo vemos como un túnel la
cantidad de chicas que iniciaron en un
momento sean muy pocas lo podemos ver en
las carreras universitarias la cantidad
de stevens se inscriben ahora el 16 por
ciento ese 16 por ciento nos llega al
final muy pocas llegan al final de
recibirte de recibirse de esas carreras
empezamos a trabajar en todo este
contexto en todo este cambio sistémico
las chicas empezaron a venir a nuestros
programas empezamos a acompañarlas para
que ellos se transforman en creadoras y
no solamente usuarias de tecnología para
mostrarle modelos a seguir para que
ellos puedan identificarse con personas
en el sector porque no se puede ser lo
que no se puede ver
las chicas están desarrollando más de
200 aplicaciones ya con impacto social
las sigue pasando por nuestro programa
desarrollan más de 200 aplicaciones con
impacto social para resolver problemas
que ellas ven en su comunidad en temas
como acoso callejero violencia bullying
suicidios son cosas que ya ven todos los
días y ahora tiene las herramientas para
ellos transformarse en las creadoras de
esas soluciones y no sólo eso sino que
están siendo líderes en sus comunidades
están volviendo a sus comunidades y
están compartiendo todo lo que vivieron
en estos programas están devolviendo a
su propia escuela lo que ellas
aprendieron con nosotros
están dando charlas tep
están hablando en espacios como estos
están compartiendo lo que ellas viven
chicas en tecnología empezó en 2015 con
23 chicas que participaron de un
programa y al día de hoy estamos en 57
localidades de argentina llegamos desde
misiones hasta ushuaia vemos el contexto
de todo lo que está pasando en el país y
creamos programas que abarquen y encaren
las necesidades de chicas que no
solamente en capital federal sino que
viven en el centro de córdoba y no sólo
eso sino que estamos creando datos y
estamos creando investigaciones que
antes no habían en nuestro país y eso
nos está ayudando a impactar en millones
de personas porque lo que no se puede
medir no se puede cambiar
es el helado
eso es todo lo que venimos logrando con
chicas en tecnología pero también
después nos encontramos con el lado b el
lado b es que una vez que las chicas
pasan por nuestros programas
generalmente las invitan a medios de
comunicación a diarios a dar entrevistas
a nosotros mismos nos pasa una vez que
salen nuestras entrevistas o nuestras
notas recibimos comentarios como estos
que nos vuelven a contrastar con este
contexto con estas construcciones
sociales que nos dicen que las mujeres
no tienen que ocupar esos espacios o que
las mujeres son inteligentes pero
también lindas y te cosifican
entonces una vez que nos atrevemos
también y que tomamos las riendas
rompemos las cajas y salimos
nos encontramos con esta realidad
lo que más me interesa de sallent de
esta charla es que este lado ve es algo
que todos nosotros podemos empezar a
cambiar hoy todas las personas que están
en esta sala en este momento pueden
empezar a trabajar de la misma forma que
lo hacemos con chicas en tecnología
desde sus espacios para romper con estas
cajas para cerrar esta brecha ustedes
desde su lugar pueden motivar a todas
las personas que están alrededor suyo
hombres y mujeres a no limitarse por los
conceptos que la sociedad tiene del
lugar que tiene que ocupar un hombre o
una mujer
ustedes
tienen el poder para cambiar la realidad
suya y de todas las personas que los
rodean de la misma forma que los estamos
haciendo con chicas en tecnología muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]